short-film number three in the can wanna
know how it was made
I'm your man just read these lyrics and
sing along to the strangers in the bed
making up song not really now I do
actually feel like I have enough to talk
about to warrant making an entire video
just on the topic of writing this film
but for now I'll just give you the
abridged version basically after making
my last film offline I learned that you
can't really tell a story about eight
different characters in ten minutes
and expect to learn very much about them
so for strangers I decided to just focus
in on two characters in the hopes that
that would give us a bit more time to
learn about who they actually are this
is also the first film that I can say I
actually wrote by myself too which is
quite nice but almost every single draft
of the film also went through the
Michael Aranda filter and I truly don't
think the script would have been
anywhere near as good as it is if it
hadn't been for his help now as my last
two films of open shot on-location the
big new pre-production challenge to
figure out this time was how do you
build a set and honestly as the director
I'm lucky enough to have other more
intelligent people figure that out for
me the multi-talented Emily Diana Ruth
came back as producer and alongside Anna
Paige and her team they figured out how
to make an American hotel room in the
middle of London and on a very small
budget as well now to be fair yes we
could have just booked a hotel room and
shot the whole film there it would have
been much simpler but we wouldn't have
been able to take out the walls of the
room so the Kiran the director of
photography could get those lovely big
wide shots and he wouldn't have had
complete control of the lighting for the
different times of day and we wouldn't
have been able to pick out all of the
furniture and the colors for the room to
help set the tone of the film so I'm
gonna go ahead and say I think having a
set was worth it and then we filmed the
movie and that was hard I was trying to
tell a more dramatic story this time
around but as I soon found out drama
it's really bloody complicated so pretty
much all of my focus this time went into
directing the actors it was fortunate
for me then that Jack and John the two
leads weren't just talented but also
just really lovely people the trickier
scenes to figure out were also the most
fun to work on no doubt because they
just seemed excited to try and do the
best jobs they could and I really
appreciated that there's also no way we
would have made it through this shoot if
it wasn't for Jamie the assistant
director who kept us all on time and to
wish I could have for every single film
I ever make but she has just recently
moved back to Canada where she is from
so I just have to hope that strangers
isn't the last thing we ever worked on
together that would be really sad now
after my tragic experience of trying to
edit the last film by myself this time I
shared editing duties with someone else
namely Craig J and although
unfortunately he wasn't able to stick
around for the whole project having him
there at the start and being able to
give him notes on the cut instead of
having to assemble the whole thing by
myself was so much nicer the bulk of my
editing work went into fine-tuning the
cut and also doing all of the visual
effects in fact I think there might
actually be more visual effects in this
film than in my last two films combined
although hopefully if I did my job
correctly you didn't notice any of them
I also want to give special mention to
Todd Bryant inand Dan Pugsley who did
the music and sound design respectively
I think they've ever really helped to
set the mood of the film and Dan's sound
especially really helps to make the
rooms feel like a real places hey hello
you still in Newark I am we are
officially on the same continent you
okay it's easy to forget sometimes I
think just how important sound in film
actually is now I'm actually recording
this in advance of releasing the film so
while I am definitely proud of it I
think it's my favorite of the film's
I've made so far I've got no idea what
you think of it maybe it's rubbish and
I'm just an idiot but I hope you like it
I am still planning on making two more
short films although this time I'd like
to try and make something a bit longer
so my plan is to make them narrative ly
connected so we'll see how that goes but
we passed the halfway point at least so
if I fail I already fell 40% and I can
live with that so goodbye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
Hey hello we are officially on the same
continent you okay just wondering why
you're not on the plane right now with
your connecting flight delayed